the Biden Administration facing another
huge scandal at the border while
Republicans lay into the man in charge
of it DHS secretary Alejandro mayorkas
hit with two brutal days of grilling on
Capitol Hill with the questions getting
downright personal at times watch here
do you disagree with the head border
patrol agent when he said that our
border is not secure Congressman I have
testified to that issue so you do
disagree with him you disagree with your
chief of border patrol I respectfully do
in that regard how
going to let this
let this congresswoman let me assure you
that we're not letting it go on we are
fighting this no I reclaim my time
you're a liar we're done done with your
lives to America
is also taking heat after a shocking
report it revealed that the White House
ignored repeated warnings about migrant
children being exploited the kids forced
to work under dangerous conditions in
factories and slaughterhouses Across
America Republicans demanding answers on
why they turn to Blind Eye
have you seen these numbers these are
reports of trafficking and abuse of
Migrant children you can see a massive
surge that begins to happen when oh when
you come to office in 2021 the horrific
exploitation of children is something
that we do not condone you are
incorrectly attributing it to our
policies this is a policy issue I
totally disagree with the secretary he
actually waived the background checks on
the sponsors this was their decision
their policy decision to waive the
background checks on these sponsors
that's why this situation has occurred
with these uh you know forced labor
judge talk about that because if you
don't do a background check on the
sponsor then on the back end you can't
then blame the Republicans for that
you know the the problem is when I was
at the border about three years ago Dana
they had there was a woman there who was
there to protect the children she came
over to talk to me and she said to me
there are people taking these children
who are unaccompanied and we don't know
who they are they're not getting DNA
from the kids they're not fingerprinting
the kids they're unaccompanied and then
they are given to people we don't know
who they are and I remember saying
that's crazy and now it's confirmed if
you read the article in the New York
Times and you hear what's going on we've
got a real problem at the border it's
it's not bad enough we've got almost
four million million people we've got
400 000 who have criminal records that
we know of in this country and now we
can't even assimilate them because we've
got 2 million backlog in the immigration
court and now we've got this this child
abuse issue which I believe they are
complicit with because they were
allowing it to happen they are not
identifying the children or the sponsors
they're just letting them go who thinks
the border is a cure nobody thinks the
border is secure and just today there
was a family a grandmother a family of a
grandmother and a seven-year-old who
were brought to the hearing and they
wanted to know why their the grandmother
and seven-year-old were killed in a
chase by a Smuggler as a result of you
know these policies this is all bad all
the way around Gerardo one of the things
that happens with these sponsors is that
sometimes they will then accept the
child
and then that child has to work off the
debt and to pay for room and board and
things like that and so what's happening
is that these children are then instead
going to work and factories are
overnight and they're not going to
school and we know what that results in
later on it's like indentured servitude
from the uh from the medieval uh times
it's horrible I'm not going to defend
the Biden administration at all on this
the border is uh out of control the
whole world wants to live in America we
need a wall uh the the sponsors of these
children have be vetted much more
strenuously it's it's horrific they
think that a that a young child boy or
girl is given to a stranger who then
puts the kid to work uh that and and
maybe uh even an illegitimate work sex
work yeah and so forth uh it's really
bad I I think that I have to get past
the distraction of Marjorie Taylor green
and the the gross rudeness that is not
designed to elicit truth or to find some
way out of this problem but rather to
showboat this man majorcus is uh the
scapegoat of a problem that is endemic
it is institutional it goes back to the
Trump Administration and the Obama
Administration before that and then the
Bush Administration before that we need
to control the Border but we have to
understand that the Epic scope of this
problem the reporting uh Bill uh uh
malusian and our other colleagues and
the with the drones and the so forth it
is undeniable now you have to believe
your eyes that this is a terrible
terrible problem that needs uh both
parties working together in a bipartisan
fashion to fix it not grandstanding not
a slandering uh the Secretary of a
Department of Homeland Security if I
could just jump in I think that
showboating is a bit of an issue a major
issue when it comes to I mean the
Democrats also right because it is
you're right it is a massive issue and
we need to get to the root causes of
this the Democrats got that right by
saying okay we need to get to get to the
root causes of this and then appointed
Kamala and that's pretty much all that
happened other than they got billions of
dollars for this and even an article in
CNN not here at Fox News CNN from
earlier this year said Kamala talks
about it only occasionally since it's
become an issue for Biden I think that
if you want to be bad at your job you
should just work for the government just
seeing these debates on TV all day like
did they know or did they not know who
in the country has a job where if you
something like this of a much smaller
scale was going on there'd be debates
over okay were you just very negligent
or did you completely just not care
about your job we'd be fired long before
something like that I feel like this is
something that politicians are far more
interested in winning arguments about
who's worse and who's wrong than
actually solving it and this is a huge
major humanitarian issue I was going to
ask you Brian about mallorca's
performance himself I mean he is very
good at dodging questions and the House
Republicans are saying they want to
impeach him of course I don't think that
necessarily works in the Senate though I
was told today by Mark green that well
maybe because they never thought that
the president would go with them on the
D.C crime criminal Rights bill that
maybe they'll be able to get Democrats
to go along with them on this what do
you think does anybody think that the
next major orgas will be better the next
person coming in will probably be the
guy uh Biden is the head of the he's he
sets the policy exactly uh but he knows
better although this is what gets me and
by the way a side note the judge was
looking at your notes when you were
talking I know your friends but it's if
she says the same thing as you the next
block
uh judge and I are like this we have
prom dates
nobody could read that handwriting so
you're safe uh I I always say to myself
uh Thomas Holman said mallorca's knows
better he says he knows exactly what to
do when he's choosing not to do it and
for him to go against his border patrol
who came out and said the border is not
secure he's going against his own border
patrol Chief I have to disagree you have
to disagree we were watching the border
patrol Jeeps is 100 right in fact he
underplayed it and I just say to myself
all the time is this the policy and then
this this story comes out about Susan
Rice backed up by five different people
and she is maybe calling the shots
behind the scenes more than we'll ever
know and maybe the story written by the
bite Administration will talk about her
uh rice vented in a note that she's
scribbled in a memo detailing the
position of Advocates who believe that a
pandemic era border closure was
compelling parents to send unaccompanied
minors to the Border really she goes
this is BS what is leading to the
voluntary separation is our generosity
to the unaccompanied minors so she knows
the policy of come one come all is
causing all the kids to come which sends
him into our country if they stack up
he's she's like they're like Trump
they're going there they're abusing kids
so they got to quickly disperse him to
sponsors who aren't qualified or vetted
who get money for taking kids they don't
care about can I just stay at one PS I
don't discreet with anything you said
Brian but why not prosecute some of
these employers when was the last time
you saw a prosecution for child labor
exploitation was the last time you saw
uh you know uh one of these uh meat
packing plants or poultry processing
plants where the owners got prosecuted
it's the very last leg first you attract
them then you let them come in then let
you stay then you get a Nike outfit and
a bus trip to any City you want and a
hotel to stay in and then food and then
the idiots and the criminals come in and
suck them out and then put them into
spots here's the difference do I want to
prosecute the pedophile absolutely but
more important than that is I don't want
the children delivered to the pedophile
and that's where the problem is said
much better than me I wish I could do it
again
since we have a couple seconds here on
the idea that they would try to impeach
mallorcas is it a waste of time do they
spend more time on the Biden piece you
know what it's not going to happen uh if
they have the votes in the Senate that
would be great but you know I think it's
important to I think it's important for
them to be able to say look we don't buy
what you're saying and you know whether
they call them a lie or whatever he is
he is not telling the truth the border
is not secure four million people coming
through is not secure these are historic
numbers there right now are 40 000
waiting in Juarez to come across as soon
as 42 is down don't forget don't forget
uh in Panama where there's 1200 to 1500
Chinese citizens dressed like they're
ready for suburban suburban America to
come to our country what are they up to
I gotta see that video all right I have
a smart comment but I'm going to swallow
it hi winner Brian Kilmeade I want you
to do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now